dak good morning believe nation my name
is Alex and my one word is belong and I
believe the world would be a better
place if more people felt that they
belonged so to help you on your journey
today's messages be driven over to you
David Goggins the first ultramarathon
wasn't smart at all at all just so
basically happened was I was at military
freefall school with Morgan Latrell
marcus luttrell if you guys don't know
was the lone survivor the guy he was in
a bad op-op went bad he was the only
Navy so that lived long story short you
got to get the book read lone survivor
great story Morgan is Marcus - Charles
twin brother and I was there with Marcus
so what happened was myself and Morgan
were freefall school at the same exact
time Marcus was in the worst incident in
still history so I knew that Marcus
might be dead he wasn't dead everybody
was dead so I actually brought Morgan
you know I actually told Morgan hey man
your brother wasn't a bad incident I
don't know if he's alive I know what's
going on long story short
Marcus is alive and I go on to want to
raise money for families all these guys
died they all had kids I want to raise
money for the Special Operations Warrior
Foundation it's a foundation where 100%
tuition goes to these kids to go to
college you know a full tuition whatever
so I found this great foundation I'm
going to raise money for it so I see
know what I have to Google something
that's that's evil something very hard I
knew nothing about ultramarathons
I hadn't even run a marathon I knew
nothing about this world so I googled
that little the top 10 hardest races in
the world and what comes up is about
water 135 so hundred thirty-five mile
race through Death Valley in the
summertime I thought it was a stage race
I thought was a race where you run like
20 miles set up camp you know
barbecue outside and then go run some
more the next day
so I called the race director up at the
race that said hey Chris the name is
Chris Causton I want to do your race so
we had a long conversation you know I
was I was much heavier then and I had to
put running shoes on over a year how
heavy are you at this point I'm around
between 240 to 270 whoa I'm in there I'm
in that register I've my weight is
buried a lot through the SEAL Teams and
I was so team so I was a heavy guy but
the long and short of it all was I am
put running shoes on in over a year I
was a big-time power lifter I lifted
weights heavy that's what I did I just
got back home from Iraq went straight to
freefall school and then this happened
so I called Chris costing up on a
Wednesday he says look man the only way
you can qualify for my race is to run
100 miles at one time in 24 hours or
less there happened to be a race that
Saturday so four days later and he said
if you qualify by running a hundred
miles or less in 24 hours I will
consider you my race I'm gonna cut to
the chase I signed up for this race it's
called a San Diego one day were you
running around a one-mile track for 24
hours to see me miles you can get my
goal was 100 miles so I got 2 miles 70
and I cleared 70 miles in like 12 13
hours pretty quickly but I was done my
feet were broken
I was stretched fractured shin splints
muscles were tearing I was in bad shape
I was eating rich crackers and drinks
and that's all I had no water didn't
know what the hell I was doing out there
had on some tube socks
it was just ridiculous it was it was a
clown show so I sat down at Mile 70 and
at this time I was married and I look at
my wife and I was like I'm messed up bad
so I literally start to turn white and
when a black guy turns white you're
pretty so here I am I'm off in this
chair I'm at Mile 70 they got 30 miles
to go I'm jacked up I got to go to the
bathroom and the bathrooms like 20 feet
from me supporter party I can't get all
the chair so I'm peeing blood down my
leg whoa pooping up my
pack and I got thirty miles to go and
I'm I can't stand up cuz my my blood
pressure's all messed up I've been in
three whole weeks
Ranger School overcome so many obstacles
in my life this last 30 miles of this
race is when I realized a human being is
not so human anymore we have the ability
to go in such a space if you're willing
to suffer and I mean suffer your brain
and your body once connected together
can do anything and this 30 miles was
the life-changing moment I was out of it
I wasn't the worst pain in my entire
life I was to me on the brink of death
and I was able to chuck this 30 damn
miles into small pieces I was so driven
and I'm not gonna say motivated cuz
motivations crap motivation comes and
goes when you're driven whatever's in
front of you will get destroyed so I sat
in this chair and I was so driven to
succeed in this race and at this time
everyone's were you thinking about the
guys that died and I'm not gonna lie to
you I wasn't this became a personal
thing
this became me against this race me
against the kids that called me [ __ ]
me against me it just became something
that I took so so violently personal and
I broke this thing down into small
pieces I said okay I got to get
nutrition I gotta be able to stand up
before I can get off this curb and go
off this chair and be able to go 30
miles so I went through all these small
steps and I was able to stand up and
then from standing up
I was literally walking around with my
wife at the time and she goes she's not
gonna make the time she goes you mean
you're walking like 30 something at
miles I got tomorrow 81 and the second
she said that I'm not gonna make the
time I ran the last 19 miles non-stop
and I can show you right now when we get
done with this smack I want to show you
right now this was years ago
and I had to put compression tape
on my own and I had so this was years
ago I had literally the size of half
dollars I had to get compression tape
and I taped up my ankles and i taked up
my feet and that's how I got through
that race it was like a hematoma I mean
what do we well though it's not happened
was like my shins hurts so bad from
having stress fractures that's the only
way I could continue on was I taped it
so I wasn't doing the flexor motion that
that activates your shins
so I taped my ankles and my shins up and
I got that from because of my throat
hell week they were good let me go back
through you know train anymore right so
I literally went through all the buds my
last field training with stress
fractures and shin splints and how I did
it was I would take my ankles all the
way up to my calf every morning so for
the first hour the pain was excruciating
but what happened is my feet would go
numb now did that every single day for
six months whoa that's how I got through
my third hell because I was so broken
from the first two that the commander
said hey the CEO said this year last
time I sent you through so that's how I
got the idea to do that so with the
right and people may listen to this and
say this guy is sadistic he's crazies
know if you know how I came up you
realized I was just a scared kid that
found drive and passion to be something
much better than what he thought he was
that's all it is
self-talk and visualization of the two
keys to my success I believed for that
last time 19 miles I was indestructible
because I took myself in that chair
crapping up my back peeing blood in my
leg shin splints stress fractures I used
all that for motivation versus
negativity I use a fear motivation I
said to myself who on this earth would
still be going right now you are you are
you got to be the hardest core on the
planet is it true
I don't give at that time it got me to
the finish line of death race I believed
it I believed it today I believed it
enough to where my body said he's not
going to stop and that's I took all the
negative things I need to go to the
hospital this and that and I uses all
who the hell could even get on that
chair you did who the hell would even
think about taping stress fractures up
you did all those things I'd use for
motivation to be driven you have to push
pass your discomforts
I love David's story because it talks
about mentality pushing past physical
limits so here's a guy with broken feet
bleeding urinating defecating himself
he's got to do a hundred kilometers in
24 hours he's only got 30 or 20 left but
what I want you to focus especially more
importantly on is don't get so
overwhelmed and paralyzed and think of
him as an exception he is a rule and
we're all every single day capable of
being incredible and driven in the
things that we value and we find
important so I am going to give you an
example something that happened to me
recently in the past month and a half
I've been trying to live a more healthy
lifestyle because I want to have more
energy in my day-to-day life so I went
back into the gym last week and I
started swimming now I hate swimming but
it's an amazing full-body workout and so
when I went to the swimming pool for the
second time I set a goal for myself that
I'm gonna do six laps then four laps
then walking two laps so as I started
swimming first lap I'm doing great
second lap I'm really killing it I'm
getting pumped up by the third lap my
spine starts to wonder and it starts to
wonder oh I got to do this email I got a
respond to this task and I started
getting distracted from my goal what's
in front of me
I started slowing down steady getting a
little bit more tired my breath started
to get a little more shallow and so I
caught myself in that moment
I shook my head as I'm swimming I'm like
no I gotta focus on something that's
important and so my mind I visualize
myself seeing my body more important and
then just like fit but more energetic
and just exuding energy and suddenly my
body had this inner rise of power and
energy and I started increasing as ice
water started swimming again so I'm
getting through my third laughs I'm
getting through my fourth laughs I got
two more to go getting into my fifth
flop I'm already getting tired I'm
finishing my fifth lap I'm getting ready
to do my last lap and about 20 feet away
from the edge I'm almost there
my body really starts to get heavy my
muscles really start to get sore and I
look at that edge I'm like you know I
can't I can't I can't do it let me just
stop let me walk it off it's okay I'll
try another time it was too much for me
to chew but I did it and what pushed me
was I just focused on that edge and I'm
like I just have to reach the edge
that's all I have to do I don't need to
think about the other laps I'm about to
do after I rest none of that I need to
reach that edge and so I push through
and I reach that edge and so how many
times in your life when you're focused
on some goal on a diet talking to some
girl you find some kind of excuse when
you are uncomfortable when you feel
overwhelmed when your muscles are
exhausted when you're mentally
exhausting you come home and you're like
you know what I wanted to learn Spanish
but I'm so tired from work I'll deal
with it tomorrow or I'll deal with it
the next day the only way you can ever
truly be driven is enjoy the discomfort
enjoy the exhaustion and push past it
because right now I'm still riding the
high of last week of not stopping 20
feet away and then disliking and hating
myself for it
when you focus on David's story or even
my story you have to understand that
every single day you can be an
unstoppable force for the dreams and
goals you envision for yourself but the
only way that can happen is by not
giving up
when things get hard or things get
uncomfortable and focusing on taking
your big visions of healthiness more
energy happier relationship better
father whatever it is into small
everyday chunks if you do that you're
gonna be a star so the question of the
day is what is one thing you can do
today to make yourself a little bit
uncomfortable but get you closer to your
goal I want to give a quick shout out to
Dave Walker Dave thank you so much for
purchasing a copy of Evans book your one
word it really means a lot to us thank
you so much for watching we believe in
you and we hope you can seem to believe
in yourself and whatever your one word
is and we'll see you tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso if you had
to think of one word that's most
important to you or that sums you up or
that would be like a little beacon hey
believe nation if you want to know what
the most important one word is for Tony
Robbins Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey
will.i.am and Howard Schultz I have a
very special secret video for you check
the description for details